hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game and a very enjoyable one at
that that ended pretty much uh as soon
as it started it's it's a really sharp
attacking game between two very very
sharp players even sharich of croatia
versus yanni pomnishi and uh uh like uh
like i said even uh in the round that
we've covered where alireza played
against charizard it is a wonder game
but even alireza did not play the open
ceiling against him as he is really
known as a incredibly sharp sicilian
player with both white and black
so here you will just see how how sharp
i mean so even has the white pieces and
he opens with e4
and again this is one of those games
where
you just see how unforgiving main lines
can be in chess so e4 we have c5 the
sicilian defense by nipple knight to f3
d6 and now d4 the open sicilian captures
captures knight to f6 knight to c3 and
a6 the night of sicilian is on the board
with bishop to e3 and pawn to e5 uh the
english attack uh so the knight has to
move knight back to b3 and bishop to e6
with f3 again this is all main line
bishop to e7 and queen to d2 and here uh
the main line uh when i say the main
line i mean the absolute main line is
the castle uh young goes for the second
most popular option that is knight b to
d7 and even replies with g4 so it's the
the most standard setup one's on f3 e4
you want to play g4 h4 h5 g5 and crush
the uh the black king uh and of course
jan will castle queen side or in fact he
might even uh and that queen said he
will castle a king side or he will uh
keep the king in the center of the board
so here we have h6 preventing g5
and queen side castles by evan we have
pawn to b5 nipple starts his expansion
on the queen side and the king to b1
always very useful when the dark square
bishop is still on the board if the
position opens up the knight moves the
bishop moves somehow this bishop comes
to g5 the king is in c1 uh you know it
it's not the only reason of course also
the rook will come to c8 at some point
maybe so the king really does belong on
b1 sometimes even a1 so here knight to
b6 uh the knight now coming to
c4 also you have control over d5 so you
might be able to push it but um white
also has very excellent control over the
d5 square so here queen to f2 attacking
the knight and rook to b8 now
and here we have ponte h4
also very popular is to go for this
knight to c5 it's a tricky idea of
course the pawn uh cannot uh capture you
you lose the queen but then black uh
gets the initiative going with pawn to
b4 so that even decides to just keep it
uh where it is so he starts advancing
the pawns on the king side pawn to h4
and now uh here usually queen to c7 and
b4 are played uh but nepal plays a move
that has only been played once before
and that is knight to a4 and it would
seem that nepo mixed up his lines or he
didn't it's not exactly that this move
is losing it's that it's it's so far on
the edge of of just uh being dead lost
uh that uh even if he didn't mess up
lines i believe nepo is one of those
players that
he's the only one that would play this
willingly uh you know as he often plays
weird lines and uh
you know uh
thrives in those those positions but
okay uh knight to d5 uh and now bishop
captures on d5 e captures and we finally
reached a new position there is one game
where queen to see seven was played it
was played in 2002 between greg shahadi
and johan alvarez marcus but here we
have knight to d7 and it is now as of
move 16 that we have a completely new
game and uh now bishop to d3 if you
allow the engine to brute force this the
engine just says f4 and black can resign
of course now now that you see it you
you kind of believe the engine but it's
still very hard
to realize why he captures on f4 bishop
captures uh and what do you play uh i
mean your king is in the center of the
board but still it it's a complete mess
of a position a point is if you cancel
then g5 uh h5 let's say knight to d4 the
knight is coming to f5 uh there are
still moves to be made but with you know
perfect play shouldn't be a problem uh
but okay here we have bishop to d3 even
chooses a different approach we have
queen to c7 and now pawn to g5
we have knight uh beat uh a knight to d
to b6 getting the other knights to c4 g
captures on h6 g captures and now pawn
to f4 this move of course will be played
at some point so now it's time to open
up the at the black king's position and
now uh if you capture on d5 you don't
really gain all that much for example
knight captures we're just going to move
the bishop keep it to control all of
these squares and now uh
it's very hard to find a good move for
black if he captures here you just play
rook rook to e1 and uh
you don't have an attack with black uh
but your position is just uh uh you know
completely wide open white will you know
with a few more moves in white will have
a very easy uh time playing this like
queen d4 attacks the knight attacks the
rook and h8 the position is too full of
holes so after f4 uh knight to c4
instead by nepo uh now attacking the
bishop and putting pressure on that b2
pawn with both of the knights and so
even eliminates the knight even though
this opens up the b file but he
calculates it properly b
bishop captures on c4 b captures on c4
and now uh your knight is hanging and
you have to decide what to do here so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the absolute best move for white
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on not touching the
knight as that would be pretty weird and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is of course f captures an
e5 that's the move that wins the game
and uh nipple doesn't really have a
better option uh than to capture the
knight here so he does see captures on
b3 a captures on b3 kicking away the
knight and knight to c5 but now just a
rook h to f1 you could also play rook to
e1 you could also play characters on d6
the black king is just too weak in the
center of the board even goes for rook
to f1 as it comes with the immediate
thread of queen captures on f7 so nipple
defends it rook to f8 and did not bishop
captures and h6 goes after the rook uh
it's the simplest way to play this uh we
have d captures on e5 and now bishop
captures an f8 as the rook cannot move
bishop captures and now pawn to h5 now
if you start marching this pawn up the
board is game over so nipple has to keep
an eye on that h6 square but even finds
an instant breakthrough that
you know completely uh shadows jan's
position and that is pawn to d6 he gives
up this pawn to completely discoordinate
ions pieces as now you can't keep an eye
on the d6 spawn on the f7 pawn and on
the h6 square that is crucial for this
white pawn to start marching forward so
it's basically the principle of three
weaknesses which is not something we see
very often so rook captures on v6 rook
captures on d6 we end up bishop captures
and d6 if you play queen captures of
course queen captures an f7 so bishop
captures on d6 but now we have full
control over the h6 square and that
means the pawn starts marching forward
quant h6
nepo starts advancing the e pawn but
just h7 with bishop to e5 guarding the
h8 square but now queen to g1 preparing
check and then we are going to promote
this pawn and there is no move that
young can make here few more moves were
played knight to e6 to help out with the
defense of the king but now just queen
to g8 with check knight to f8 and eight
uh and now first rook to f5 not going
for h8 right away uh first attacking the
bishop hoping for rook captures bishop
queen captures and then this uh but you
don't really have to do this bishop to
d4 uh we have h8 with queen bishop
characters and h8 a queen captures an h8
and he was in this position on move 36
uh that yanni palmishi resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
you're down the exchange uh and there's
really no more you can make if you start
pushing the pawn rookie five just wins
the pawn uh so that that that would be
weird and if you try something like king
e7 to unpin maybe to get the knight into
the game we can even trade queens i mean
there are better moves but even this is
you know good enough to to actually win
the game just through a capture sun e4
uh and of course the position is
completely winning so really really
weird game uh shari shows just how far
his preparation goes as like we
mentioned he's also a member of the
magnus crossing camp uh and obviously
they are doing quite a lot of work but
i'm pretty sure he does quite a lot of
work on on his own as well uh and here
uh you know but i still i still can't
decide if uh uh the move that um uh
nipple went for this knight the c4 idea
uh sorry knights day for idea is is his
uh
uh own choice uh did he mix up lines or
the or does he know that that this is
incredibly incredibly tricky and he
still decided to play it but even just
pulled it off properly so it's hard to
say with nipple you never know at this
time uh you know regardless of of which
it is it didn't uh it didn't work
uh so yeah that's the game i really hope
you guys enjoyed it uh always play the
sicilian uh you will have great games
with both white and black it's it's a
beautiful opening uh i would like to
thank dominic albers gordon mercer some
console of the right travis and michael
calbert for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing uh to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and of course
continuing the coverage of the super
united rapid and blitz tournament in
croatia until it finishes
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day